Kerry Lake lost the 2022 Arizona
gubernatorial election she lost what I
mean by that is her opponent Katie Hobbs
got more votes and as a result Katie
Hobbs will be the governor I think
six-year-olds would understand this who
got more votes well Katie Hobbs got more
votes oh so who won Katie Hobbes won so
what does that mean it means Katie Hobbs
becomes the governor not Kerry Lake
because Kerry Lake lost because Kerry
Lake received fewer votes it sounds so
simple and yet Kerry Lake simply will
not go away Carrie Lake won't simply say
it's over uh Carey Lake delivering
another one of these highly filtered
I've never seen a blur filter the way
that Carrie Lakes videos have
she put out a video
updating her supporters about her fight
Now understand what it means that she is
fighting this
this small detail is so important
she's fighting for an election where she
lost
because her opponent received more votes
it's that simple and yet here she is
question is she grifting or is she
actually fighting I don't know let's see
if we can figure it out Arizona is
Carrie Lake and I wanted to update you
on what's happening in our fight against
Arizona's sham elections and those who
run them for starters I want you to know
that I am firmly in this fight with you
Maricopa County just couldn't wait to
certify their botched election the
botched election where half of election
day voting centers were inoperable that
is a lie half of the voting centers were
not inoperable there were a few machines
that were malfunctioning for a portion
of election day we've talked about it
already
the botched election where election day
printers caused Mayhem across the county
the botched election where arizonans
were expected to wait in line two three
four even five hours simply to exercise
their sacred right to vote now remember
in other places other counties are
overwhelmingly Democratic areas making
people have to wait for hours to vote is
a strategy from the right they closed
down polling places and early voting in
overwhelmingly or places parts of the
states that favor Democrats in order to
create long voting lines which they say
is fine but here lines are indicative of
suppressing the Republican vote think
about that
arizonans were told to throw their vote
into a drawer where it might ultimately
end up in a plastic bin or a trash bag
Maricopa County where it took two weeks
to count is the poster child for broken
botched elections but if you bring up
any of these issues you are labeled an
election denier or well when you're
lying you are called a liar conspiracy
theorist they don't want us talking
about our shoddy elections under any
circumstances
they shut us down and made us fear
exercising our freedom of speech and
they canceled anyone who questioned past
elections
because of that many Americans did not
speak out and nothing was done to shore
up elections and now we are paying the
price again now remember nothing was
done to shore up elections in the
immediate aftermath of 2016 when real
vulnerabilities were identified
including the vulnerability of our our
elections broadly to foreign influence
many particularly Democrats tried to
actually do something about it
Republicans didn't want to hear it Mitch
McConnell didn't want to hear it so when
we identified a real problem we did try
to fix it they didn't want to fix it
because they like the results now that
they've identified imaginary problems
they say nobody else wants to fix it
because it's part of the way that the
left is stealing elections it is quite
literally backwards from reality
Arizona
America if we do not stand up and speak
up right now about the most dishonest
elections in the history of Arizona I
truly fear for our future our sacred
vote is supposed to be the great
equalizer of the people
and right now our vote has been trampled
upon we must work hard right now to save
it this is our last chance
those of you who are speaking out about
what happened on November 8th those who
testified before the corrupt Board of
Supervisors that includes the people who
said that there was treason the people
who said it was demonic that that's who
she's talking about we looked at clips
of that yesterday thank you and God
bless each of you the people she's
thanking many of them are insane I am
with you
here's what I'm busy working on I'm
working with a team a patriotic talented
lawyers on a legal case to challenge The
Botch elections now remember many of
those patriotic Talent talented lawyers
who got involved in 2020
many of them were disbarred
my team and I realized how important
this case is and what is at stake we
will file this case in accordance with
Arizona state law and you'll want to
stay tuned for this one trust me
so many have expressed concern about
Maricopa County's certification okay I
think you get it this reeks of
desperation and it reeks of grift Trump
fought in quotes fought which was really
fundraised money right the the last big
grift although maybe the last big grift
is is him now running for president
again Trump fought for two years and he
got nothing are they really going to
fall for this all over again so let's go
through the facts just so we're clear on
them Maricopa County officials said to
numerous media Outlets including to USA
Today no extra ballots were counted at
any voting sites in the county there has
been no evidence that people who wanted
to vote were unable to vote they've seen
no evidence that the ballot drop boxes
were insecure and they have also not
been contacted by many of the
individuals that Kerry Lake and others
claim are quote working on this issue
the county has processes to ensure legal
ballots are counted one time not zero
times and also not two times the the
drop boxes were secure
the tabulators which a few of them
briefly malfunctioned on Election Day uh
were repaired even the RNC which
initially filed a lawsuit over that
withdrew the lawsuit because it was
demonstrated to their satisfaction that
everything was on the up and up this is
all made up and at this point I
genuinely don't know is this number one
a way for Kerry Lake to keep raising
money I don't know the answer to that is
this number two Kerry Lake being a True
Believer in any of the nonsense that
she's saying including that she's
fighting for the election again the
election's over we're almost a month
beyond the election she lost her
opponent one or and I'm increasingly of
the mindset that this is the most likely
explanation or
is this Kerry Lake auditioning to be
Trump's VP is that really what this is
about that much like and I know I
mentioned this yesterday many Trump
supporters who maybe didn't literally
believe Trump won in 2020. said it
because it was how you pledged
allegiance to the team it's not the
pledge of allegiance to the flag it's
the pledge of allegiance to Trump and
the way you pledge allegiance is by
saying Trump won
is Carrie Lake doing the same thing and
wanting to position herself to be
Trump's 2024 VP by saying the exact same
stuff Trump said about 2020 and quite
frankly the exact same stuff Trump has
been saying about Carrie Lake's own
election which we will get to a little
bit later let me know what you think and
remember if you're watching our clips
and you are not yet subscribed on
YouTube please subscribe this is my Jeb
Bush please clap moment please subscribe
last month over 3 million people watched
our Clips but didn't subscribe we could
get to 2 million subscribers overnight
on YouTube if the people already
watching our Clips hit that subscribe
button help us out we're going to take a
quick break and be right back
the science tells us that one of the
best ways to get consistent deep sleep
is lowering your core body temperature
when your body stays cooler at night
you're more comfortable and your sleep
is better our sponsor sleep me is the
home of chili sleep the customizable
climate controlled sleep solutions that
can improve your sleep by keeping you
cooler at night there are three
different chili sleep systems there's
the uler the cube and the new Doc Pro
with double the cooling power all three
systems are water-based temperature
controlled mattress toppers that fit
over your existing mattress to provide
you with your ideal sleep temperature
you can go as cool as 55 degrees you can
go really hot if you want I keep mine at
60. beautiful temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great I didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than I already
did go to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn
more and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night